the bags in this gym contains thousands
of ballots cast in Sunday's local
elections in Istanbul Mahmoud Tanna a
politician with the opposition CHP has
spent days here to keep a watchful eye
on that why do we wait here and keep
watch to prevent Aaron's party from
replacing the voting bags because it's
done that before they have a lengthy
record of this we have a sole purpose
securing people's rights and making sure
no one is cheated we will not allow
anyone to do this for president reject I
add one last weekend's election was one
of his heaviest setbacks in years his
Islamic rooted aka party won a majority
of votes nationwide but according to
initial results the opposition has one
key urban centres including the capital
Ankara and Istanbul a city of more than
50 million billboards like this one have
gone up in Istanbul since election night
president Allen and his candidate for
mayor Bernalillo Durham thanking the
public for their votes but actually
they're facing defeat here and if
confirmed this would be a stunning
setback for a Don himself who gained
power after being mayor of Istanbul in
the 1990s preliminary results in
Istanbul give the opposition candidate
extremely mamalu and narrow lead of
about 25,000 votes the AKP now alleges
irregularities and miscounting it has
pushed through a recount of the votes in
several districts the pro-government
Turkish media described the opposition's
unexpected success and drastic terms
they liken the election to a coup or
blame foreign powers for meddling in
Turkey's internal affairs Harun Arman of
the AKP says such accusations are
exaggerated but he also emphasizes the
vote was not a blow for the president
and let's not forget that these
elections are local elections therefore
interpreting these results as the
general election or almost like a
referendum on President Erdogan would be
wrong but even if you do that the party
and president are doing on our part
he has got 53% the the popular water in
this country let's say we have lost some
cities anything but maybe lost a few
cities will be a humbling point for us
but voters say the result sends a signal
to president add one who has to find an
answer to turkey's economic crisis I
kept the AKP deserved this result I
support the party but it was dishonest
with the people so this is what they get
this gives me hope it shows people
finally woke up and took a stand
KP didn't lose that much
the politicians understood they made
some mistakes no they're speaking in a
different tone and showing more respect
the opposition hopes its election
victory will soon be officially
confirmed its candidate Akram Imam Alou
has already changed his title on Twitter
to mayor of Istanbul meanwhile his
fellow party member marwilt Anala will
keep an eye on the ballots and monitor
the recount as long as it takes